tonight while the bite administration
complains about the lack of inclusion in
the new the taliban's new government
we're getting a picture of what life
will be like under the taliban rule
where sharia law rules supreme now
afghan women will soon be banned from
playing sports holding most jobs their
travel will also be restricted most
music is also going to be banned comedy
is banned and all women will be forced
to adhere to a strict dress code and
moral code the punishment for breaking
any of these barbaric rules is death
here with more the host of fox nation
lara logan along with the medal of honor
recipient fox news contributor dakota
meyer is with us dakota i want to ask
you
my understanding is that our
intelligence was able to track
the terrorist attack that killed 13
americans and and injured 200 more and
killed you know over 100 more
and
they had they ran up the chain they
tracked them they knew what was
happening the intel was exactly right
and that they
had the ability to take this guy out now
jennifer griffin says the pentagon
denies this report
and they didn't take out the suicide
bomber you've been looking into it i
heard you this morning talking about it
what's the latest on it
is the department of defense telling us
the truth or are they lying
yeah i mean look sean i mean are we
going to trust the department of defense
are we going to actually trust the
people who are part of the biden
administration that continue to lie to
us uh no i mean look we are talking to
the people on the ground we have
confirmed with three different sources
that were involved in this that sent it
up they had intel reporting that there
was going to be an attack uh they found
this person they actually had drone lock
on this person they sent it up and
requested to take the shot and the
response was back no for the reason
being that they were negotiating with
the tal in negotiations with the taliban
now this is coming directly from sources
who were on the ground the sources who
were actually uh involved in this
incident uh so i mean of course do you
expect the government to uh to go ahead
and take accountability because that's
what it would uh would happen if uh if
they actually admitted to this
all right let me go to you
logan we know what life was like for
women under the taliban before we see
these reports we know what they're
saying that they're going to do
i guess the the obvious question is why
would anyone expect anything different
and the idea that tony blinken is so out
of touch with who the taliban really is
and they force young girls into sex
slavery and marriage and subjugate women
in ways where they can't go to school or
work and the fact that they don't know
that and the fact that he's saying well
we're concerned about the lack of
inclusivity uh with the new government
of the taliban how dumb are these people
not to know the taliban for who they are
it's not stupidity sean they know
exactly who the taliban are they're
counting on the fact that american
people don't know who the taliban are to
sell you a pack of lies and this didn't
start with tony blinken this started
with the obama administration you can go
all the way back to right after obama
was elected this was the message from
the very very beginning that there's
good taliban and bad taliban they packed
the administration with taliban
apologists and they have just ignored
all the evidence the taliban has had
control over limited parts of
afghanistan and their rule in those
areas for the last few years has been
identical to what you're seeing now so
it's not just a question of they didn't
know they had all the evidence i've
received today footage of young women at
protests which i think are in kabul i'm
going to be releasing that when i have
been able to vet it to know for sure but
there's gunfire breaks out these women
are screaming and terrified i have
another photograph from reuters of a
taliban fighter pointing a an m16
american-made rifle probably courtesy of
the u.s military at a woman and then
another picture of her body and i'm
trying to vet and confirm that but
there's women protesting all over
afghanistan now who are being shot at
there is uh there's been a number of
police women executed as you mentioned
and the biden administration has all of
the evidence that they need they had it
before and what they're doing is just
lying to you and you know sean you
remember schindler's list right
we all know what schindler's list is
well i just you know you talked about
the special operations vets and the
biden state department and the justice
department and the agency are working
overtime to threaten and intimidate all
of those vets they're using every lever
of their power to shut down those rescue
operations to drag them out and they're
now encouraging people to go to kabul
that's the message that's going out on
these networks and i'm on a lot of these
ops rooms i am one of the people that is
trying to help rescue afghans and i'm
telling everybody that before they slap
some phony kind of charges on everybody
and try and imprison people for trying
to rescue people the same way that
they've got people in prison for going
to the capitol on january 6 right and i
want to tell you what they've actually
been doing they have ceded control to
the taliban and they have sent out to
their active duty uh forces to let them
know that all of those manifests will be
vetted by suraj haqqani this man has a 5
million bounty on his head he's one of
the most wanted terrorists in the world
that's by the us right the u.s
designated him a terrorist there are
americans who died and have been wounded
going after sarajakani and the haqqani
network there are tens of thousands of
afghans who have been killed by saraj
haqqani and now he's in charge of
security he's the man that they went to
before the u.s uh you know forces were
bombed at that airport he's the guy that
they turned to for help a known
terrorist this is who the american
people are being told is going to be our
counterterrorism partner this is the
cabinet that where tony blinken says
there's some people there with you know
questionable kind of issues right in
their past excuse me you're a designated
terrorist by the united states
government and this administration has
been breaking the law over and over
again they're now going to take
humanitarian aid which is your tax
dollars the tax dollars of soldiers
families who've died on that battlefield
and the families of 911 and they're
going to try to pass it to the taliban
you know why sean because we were
sending a pallet of cash every week to
the afghan government and the taliban
can't function without it they want that
money right and the biden administration
wants to give it to them but they're
looking for a way to get it there and
they've got a little problem here
because they were going to make
recognition of the taliban government
they were going to make that conditional
based on their actions right but look at
their actions they're going house to
house executing people right there's a
genocide or potential genocide in the
making in the pancha valley the people
we were fighting with a few weeks ago
our allies are being slaughtered by the
pakistanis and the u.s is doing nothing
someone in congress needs to ask what
are we doing about pakistan why are we
not sanctioning and stopping pakistan do
we believe in governing by fear and
terror or do we believe in democracy and
freedom great report thank you lara
logan thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else